alright everybody let's get started
block them all to this third yci seminar
on g engineering that semester I've
already lucky to have a David Keith hard
University oh if this is the reason for
this early and somewhat unusual time for
a seminar is that he's given another
seminar this afternoon actually i
believe and politics of judah nearing
and so I wanted to also add advertise
that Paula crudo season who are
interested in that and so that is at the
ISPs which is on the corner of crumble
and prospect at four-fifteen and if you
if you want directions to get to get to
that talk you can also contact me so uh
let me briefly introduce David they've
got here some PhD from MIT in physics in
1991 and after that I got one of these
Noah's oval changed fellowships spent
time at some time at Carnegie Mellon and
this sort of stayed in touch with a
group at Carnegie Mellon throughout his
career I went to Angkar and worked with
Phil rush actually was the last speaker
for the speaker beforehand of this new
engineering serious seem Viking at this
right Ne like and you were a research
scientist at Harvard yeah uh for six
years I believe went to Canada and was a
faculty member at University of Calgary
and then we turned to Harvard
couple years ago in his mouth professor
there and he also runs a startup company
in Canada carbon engineering which these
fats he is giving out a transition to be
completely full-time academic and that's
a very very dreary so far so with that I
think thank you thanks very much I think
it's great to be here so I'm really
happy to have questions and
interruptions this is a this is a topic
that is you can't avoid talking a little
bit about the public policy and ethics
of it and I'm happy to do that even in
this talk which is more technical and I
think that you know the underlying
reality is that the basic knowledge that
these things could be done is very old
that there's was for a long time a kind
of taboo in the Senate of community that
said that we shouldn't talk about them
and so just to give you some sense of
that the very first high-level report
that went to a u.s. president that had
the basic climate science right went to
President Johnson when I was two years
old and it had you know all the kind of
basic elements that we now know or
correct that tell you there's a climate
problem and I think quite bizarrely in
hindsight it tells you how the science
has changed much more slowly than our
sort of social size of how we think
about things the only thing that that
report actually suggested doing about
the problem was geoengineering but it's
just in a completely Maddy way but their
husband essentially no organized
research on this topic and that changed
a little bit I may be almost seven years
ago or so when paul crutzen published an
article didn't actually say anything new
but just the fact that he published it
sort of started to open up the space
where people was more socially
acceptable people to do research i've
ended up doing quite a lot of research
here really just because nobody else was
doing it and now there is the beginning
of serious research programs in the end
you know as you all know science kind of
follows the money and the Europeans now
have like 20 million dollars or so of
real organized research programs but
there's not really any
yet so I'll give you some overview of
some really kind of basic science story
and and some of the basic questions that
I think we don't know the answers to but
we have some preliminary answers as I
said feel free to interrupt so I think
it's useful so I'm only going to talk
about solar radiative management or
solar g much sharing and i believe it's
useful to think about these these things
is really too pretty different questions
and for now I'm just going to plunge
right into the science not talking at
all about why you do this or what the
larger kind of governance questions one
question is how you would engineer a
given radiative forcing how how well you
could engineer it what the risks and
side effects of entering that radium
forcing are so that's actually one part
of the poem is making the radiative
forcing in some way and the other heart
of problem is understanding how the
climate response so in general if we're
making a shortwave radio forcing which
was most of us have been thinking about
because it was the easiest thing but
Truda is thinking of something different
which is much cleverer but but in
general if you're thinking about a
shortwave radio a long sure we're very
enforcing of reducing the insulation
effectively it's clear that cannot
exactly compensate for the effects of
co2 and either obvious is going to isn't
going to in any way compensate for the
geochemical effects of co2 like say
ocean acidification but the question is
how how good a job you can do
compensating the climate change that
comes from co2 and the answer I think is
actually surprising to me anyways been
very surprising how good it is so i
divide things into thinking about the
risks and the efficacy and I'm just the
risks I haven't have listed or for
stratospheric sulfates but there's lots
of other technology but the risks to me
in the way I'm thinking about it are the
things that are kind of the direct side
effects of the way you do the particular
way you might do the radiative forcing
so if you put sulfate aerosols in the
stratosphere for example some of them
are going to rain down the troposphere
and they're going to add to air
pollution and kill people and in fact
myself and Steve Barrett at MIT or
calculating how many people will be
killed so that's one chain of risk and
obviously there are other ways you might
engineer the radiative forcing like
solar mirrors where the risks directress
would be much much smaller it measures
the set of questions about what i would
call efficacy which are really questions
about how well this does or doesn't
compensate and I've given a list of some
of the major issues so kind of just
jumping into some science a standard
assumption for a very long time here was
that we would do this by kind of copying
what volcanoes do volcanoes put so2 in
the atmosphere in the stratosphere so2
doesn't make particles it has to oxidize
to actual h2s afford to do that and that
takes a good fraction of a as any tether
my watch that takes a good fraction of a
month a couple weeks and once you've
made h2so4 then that wants to condense
onto particles so the standard ideas are
you going to put a foot so2 in the
atmosphere and it turns out that it
doesn't work very well even though I've
been a standard idea nobody ever done
any careful calculations about how well
it worked the problem is that if you
continuously put so2 in the stratosphere
almost all of the sulfuric acid h2so4
ends up going to existing particles and
that makes it very very inefficient
because there's two phenomena was
actually three film others two important
ones one is that just simple nice
galleries and if you have a physics
background you know there's a you can
calculate the scattering all small
particles and if you calculate the
scattering divided by the mass so that's
essentially the efficiency mass
efficiency of scattering that has a
strong peak around a tenth of micron or
so and as you get much bigger than that
for this industry refraction you end up
having really terrible scattering
efficiencies so big particles just don't
scatter well so that's one problem they
had a problem of course and that's
what's on the right here is the
gravitational setting settling velocity
in kilometers a year which is the right
kind of units because again stratosphere
is a couple kilometers you think about
the kind of depths you care about if you
get this settling velocity serve much
over a few kilometers a year then you're
getting very quick removal and so both
those problems mean that as particles
get bigger they get much less efficient
per unit sulfate at scattering sunlight
so there were a whole bunch of estimates
for you know what the total radio
forcing would be you know 024 watts per
square meter here versus the sulfur
injection rate and there
some early papers that kind of had some
estimate like this but this work that
was done by Deborah weissenstein and and
the group at ETH found that if you you
know made a more serious model at least
Debra's high-quality 2d model and
actually modeled the aerosol
microphysics you get this really strong
saturation effect where you can put as
much as some absurd 20 megatons sulfur a
year in the stratosphere and have quite
a low ready to forcing because you're
just putting more and more sulfur making
the particles bigger that are falling
out quicker so we came up with a
potential solution to this this is this
pierce at all paper so some of the same
overlapping group of people I sort of
put this group together and the idea is
simple it's that if you directly put
h2so4 from an aircraft let's say you can
easily control just by controlling the
addition rate effectively you can
control the size of the particles that
you get and so Jeff Pierce had a very
nice particle dick ulation scheme he's
an aerosol scientist who came out of the
CMU group and so we kind of coupled his
aerosol scheme to the same Debra's model
and essentially gave Deborah's mono
instead of giving an S 02 we gave the 2d
model the the actual particle size
distributions that were getting out of
the plume a couple days after a mission
and it makes an enormous difference that
kind of gets you back to this
theoretical line and even better than
the theoretic line that the people that
had because you can now have a decent
job of controlling the size of the
particles whether this really works in a
more 3d world or in the real world we
don't know so much but these are early
days I think one of the issues that is
general true this field you have to
worry about group thinks so it's fun to
publish an early paper or this may
actually have made I think you would
argue a major events in the sort of
basic ability to do stratospheric
sulfate Jo journey if you ever want to
do it but until many more people think
about this and critique it I wouldn't
have that much confidence that it's
correct I just want to give you some
idea about some of the emerging stuff at
the kind of atmospheric science physics
interface that helps you think about
this whole set of questions about how
you would do the radiative forcing yep
can you get the particles to the
altitude that you want with an aeroplane
yes turns out to be easy so separately I
don't know if I have it here oui je apt
and I gave about a hundred thousand
dollars to Aurora flight sciences which
is a leading company does help to
aircraft and I've work with Jim Anderson
helped define funded to do science and I
can't find that paper right now but it's
on my website and Aurora did a pretty
complete study so we told them don't
think about atmospheric science just do
a complete trades based study of the
cost to get either one I think two or
five million tonnes a year distributed
to altitudes up to 100,000 feet and they
looked at a bunch of different things
different aircraft designs balloons and
so on bottom line is it's absurdly cheap
and easy to do this if you wanted to get
started you would probably use region
gulfstream g550 low which one you do the
math here means that you do the whole
thing for a billion bucks a year which
is incredibly cheap and it's easy for
the science community to kind of assume
that that's a good thing but it's not
necessary good thing that means that
unilateral action by small states as
possible these costs are absurdly small
compared to the overall damages and
costs of cutting emissions and
effectively the costs are so small it is
a public policy problem this is a risk
to risk problem the risks of doing it
the risks of not doing it but the costs
are so small they're basically not going
to enter for most of the schemes we've
talked about or that I'm talking about I
think the bigger issue is how you can
improve on the effectiveness or decrease
the risks so we began to think about
other particles other than sulfates
they're there other I mean why do you
have sulfates water vapor would work
fine but water droplets evaporate too
fast no stratosphere the reason the
sulfur's there's essentially to keep the
water from evaporating in principle you
could use other materials we've done a
little bit of simulation Deborah and I
are in the middle of simulating alumina
right now alumina has a very high kicks
refraction you can make smaller
particles and their hat turns out that
there's been a lot of work done back to
the 70s on the
environmental impacts of alumina the
stratosphere because it's a product of
space shuttle exhaust so it was sort of
a good one to start on because it is a
plausible reason that actually might
have lower risk I'm not sure it does but
there was a plausible reason we thought
it did right now the results seem to be
the opposite and so there are plenty of
other things you could look at I'll show
you one that really is science fiction
in a sense but it gives you a sense of
what the limits are if if Humanity
wanted to do this so this is a paper i
published in pnas three years back or so
and it I just want to give you a sense
for a more physics science audience of
what the limits might be not that this
is the outer limit so it's possible to
make engineered particles and you could
make engineer particles that actually
levitate using something called a photo
for etiquette it's a has to do with the
fact that different surfaces have
different probability that an air
molecule will thermally equilibrate by
the surface and so if you make a thing
that has surfaces that are different you
can have quite strong levitating forces
this is not a new idea it goes back to
Erin shaft in 1910 or something there
are tons of papers on photo/frank
levitation in interstellar discs one of
the the new ideas that was in this pnas
paper mine I guess or that you need some
orienting torque to keep a little flying
saucer thing like that in the
orientation you want and what occurred
to me is that there are of course forces
other than gravity in the atmosphere so
we have the atmosphere almost everywhere
has an electric field of about a hundred
volts per meter and of course it also
has a magnetic field and so the trick
here is that you could make a thing that
hat was what if physicists were called
electorate has a permanent electric
dipole moment and that makes it want to
orient and so in this particular design
that's in that paper you'd have sort of
a 50 nanometer thick thing with a thin
aluminum layer that was thick enough to
have good solar reflection but
reasonable infrared properties and and
it would sell orient with barium
titanate which is a very common widely
known electric in principle if you could
build these things and there's no
question of theoretically good do it if
you could build up an interesting cost
the advantages might be if that's an
advantage and it's not clear it is
longer atmospheric lifetimes a big
advantage might be these things float up
to the top of the message the mesopause
so they would be out of the way of the
stratosphere so they would not directly
affect ozone but maybe they do something
else that's terrible I mean you know the
advantage of thinking of something new
is you solve one problem you know but
then maybe you create some other problem
you don't know about it's also
theoretically possible to arrange for
these particles to go to one part of the
atmosphere at least only there's some
clever tricks you could do that but it
allows you to begin to think that you
could do some zonal tuning so you could
put more the radiative forcing near the
equator or more near the poles depending
on what you want to do and finally one
of the problems with sulfate aerosols or
any of these little droplets is a lot of
the scattering of light is forward
scattering and so you change the ratio
diffuse to direct sunlight and that
affects the way plants grow its own in
general it makes plant growth more
efficient to have the same amount of
insulation but with more directly
diffuse because you're not you're not
saturating some leaves and leaving other
leaves unserved but that would still
have a big environmental impact in
changing the relative competitiveness of
different plant species you can see this
so during the Pinatubo eruption to put
eight roughly million tons of sulfur in
the stratosphere you actually see the
increase in productivity and globally
proper ecosystem productivity that has
to do we think partly with direct
diffusive lumination problems or several
papers that have looked at that but this
in principle allows you to solve that
problem to the extent you think it's a
problem because a little flapping like
this and it just has a backward
scattering to pick up on this idea from
the Pearson all paper you know smaller
particles seem nice for the optical
properties but smaller particles are
actually worse in terms of surface area
of per volume and it's the service area
that matters most directly for
stratospheric ozone impacts so this just
gives you a sense of what the ozone
impacts are recently Kate Ricky a
student i shared with dan try again I
and and Deborah Liza's time is starting
to Jim Anderson at Harvard think much
more carefully about the ozone
impacts and maybe what we've done is
commits ourselves the problem is much
more complicated than we thought and and
there are lots of ways the ozone impact
could actually go in principle either
direction so it's not clear necessarily
that adding particles to stratosphere
make less ozone you can arrange to make
more as well there are some pretty
complicated feedbacks here so this is
just a little hand drawing i had that
word in the middle of working on papers
but if you think about it the local
ozone loss depends on local water vapor
stratospheric h2o local temperature in
the stratosphere and and the service
arizal the sulfate aerosol density the
surface surface the amount of surface
area per unit volume of these aerosols
and actually not going to have much
about it your matter so I are thinking
about actual real and sexual experiments
at stratosphere to measure the stress
for chemistry and understand it better
but but if you think about the different
things that feedback on these what
you're directly doing if you add so2
from SRM what you're directly doing is
adding aerosol that's that's what you
know you're doing but there's all sorts
of indirect effects so you're changing
the temperature to change in radiative
properties but you're also the whole
point of this is to reduce the surface
temperatures or reduce climate change
and that by changing the surface
temperature will change the stratosphere
temperatures a little bit indirectly but
also in a very big deal that will change
the tropical tropopause temperature
which changes the amount of water vapor
they guess the troposphere and that
feedback is a hard to know because we
actually don't understand as well as we
would like to what controls
stratospheric water vapor so there is a
lot of feedback loops and I think in
general all the papers that have looked
at the ozone impacts of jail shearing
have kind of assumed away most of these
feedback loops they haven't looked at
the water vapor change or some of the
temperature changes and we're not
attempting to just run a GCM because we
don't really believe them we're just
trying to really think through the
physics of the different feedbacks and
try and think systemically about what's
your the big and low feedbacks here and
what knobs are might be to manage the
impacts i should say in context there's
some risk that jim anderson is worried
about that there's evidence which is
disputed that as the world gets warmer
we're going to get more water vapor
intrusions into the lower
or mid-latitude troposphere stratosphere
lower stratosphere and if we do and you
did you mind sharing you could get
pretty big ozone losses maybe I mean
this is really kind of new and disputed
science nobody knows the answer so just
to give you a very rough sense these are
some of the risks in general this field
is new enough that I think we're quite a
long way from anything it looks like
systemic risk assessed but we have kind
of individual papers looking at risks
here and there and that's about it let
me talk a little bit about efficacy so
there's some sort of standard wisdom in
this field which just turns out not to
be true and and so one of it is that
somehow this idea of adding say self ice
the stratosphere only works to bring
global temperatures back into safe to
pre-industrial or whatever you wanted
and won't help with precipitation or
there's an idea that it really only
works at a global level and doesn't work
regionally and it's really not so simple
as that so my student one Rayna Cruz
mkay tricky and I set out to really be
quantitative about the extent to which
some change in the solar forcing
actually really compensates for climate
change at a regional level so what we
did is there some a whole bunch of
climate impact literature that uses
these standard regions that have come to
be called the Georgie regions there's 23
remember something to remember you can
count the number on this list here and
so we ran in this case the client
prediction net ensembles set of models
under a co2 Ram configuration I can give
you more details if you want and then
analyze temperature changes in
temperature and precip on each of the
regions so if you think about climate
impacts I mean in the end to do real
climate impact analysis you actually
have to dig down and figure out what you
care about it's not a scientific
question depends on the values of what
you have to care about but eh not bad
common approximation in lots of the
climate impacts that you're sure is to
think about the fact that the impact is
proportional to the amount that the
climates changed compared to the
pre-existing variability and then it
might be that squared there's a lot of
evidence that impacts for quadratic so
so that you know if you raise the
temperature four degrees it's
you know more than twice as bad as
raising two degrees or change precip
similarly but also that that changing
temperature four degrees in a place
where the intern annual variability of
temperature is four degrees is not such
a big impact as it is in a place where
the International variabilities one
degree so the unit's here are the change
in the quantity temperature precip / the
the interannual standard deviation so
that's so they're normalized to be
dimensionless units so this shows you
for all these regions what happens to
temperature in a world with roughly the
point of co2 doubling and to end with a
certain amount of SRM and the same for
preset and then you can see the standard
deviations on the bottom so first one
very important thing to say is because a
statement you often hear that this
technology necessary decreases preset
that's not quite true what is true is
that yet definitely precipitous ence
responds faster than temperature so if
you decided that you wanted to bring if
you if you start with a climate increase
co2 and then did SRM to bring the
temperatures back to pre-industrial
which is what a lot of models simulate
if you did that then you end up with
precip globally lower than
pre-industrial but that's almost
certainly completely not anything to do
nobody has really thought through all
the policy suggesting we do that you
could just as well say that you start
with a climate increase co2 which
increases preset and then do enough SRM
to bring precip back to pre-industrial
which case you leave the temperature a
little bit warmer the scientifically
those are equivalent statements and it's
a public policy decision which we do is
I'll argue later you probably own twon't
to do either of them you want to do
something much more lenient and just do
a little bit of SRM so you have a bigger
chance of the benefits outweigh the
costs so you can think about this that
the response of climate models turns out
to be very linear whether the response
of the world is so linear isn't clear
the client models are amazingly linear
climate modelers typically don't agree
with this and when you write papers
saying it they complain and then you
have to publish appendices showing how
the linear I've done this thrice in my
career that they're really linear so in
the regions that we're using here so so
just pretend I have two regions this
could be
India South India and North India
temperature or it could be North
American temperature and south indian
priests it it doesn't matter just two
regions in my climate model and so co2
driven warming there's a roughly linear
response to co2 let's say or to radio
for thing actually will change those in
some particular direction and SRM will
change it in some other direction and if
it was exactly the same direction that
it would be perfect conversation but it
isn't so you can think about some
residual climate change and you can
start to think about the public policy
the trade-off that you could make
everything just perfect for region b-but
region a is too warm if that was warming
where you can do some suppose at optimum
but the question here these are just
drawings the question is what's the
actual angle fundamentally the radiative
forcing from co2 is just not the same
physics to the radio forcing from from
putting solvates in the stratosphere and
the question is to what extent is a
response those forcing similar that's
the objective question and and you can
think about this since it's roughly
linear response as as in this 12 22
times too if you like temperature and
precip so forty four dimensional vector
space how far apart are the two vectors
because in the end right I've got all
I've got those all those different
places they're all responding with
different coefficients but linearly so I
can make a big vector space of all these
things and i can ask myself how what's
the angle between the co2 vector and the
SRM vector that's a kind of basic
measure of how good the conversation is
and if you'd asked me to guess I would
have guessed the angle was like kind of
30 degrees that you know SRM was useful
in reducing climate change but really
didn't do a very good job the actual
answer we got was I think kind of
stunningly good I've still find this
very surprising so for well you've got
all these regions you got her to figure
out how to weight the regions so you
could you know you've got to decide if
you're waiting them by money if you're
an economist or by area if you just
maybe care about the natural world or
what population if you just care about
people we call it and so we don't have
any opinion but what's the right answer
but we've objectively you've got to
think about the different answers
there's no magic way to weight them so
what this is telling you is if you're
looking just a temperature
sir and you choose the amount of chima
sharing that's the best job of
compensating temperatures everywhere and
a kind of least squares sense and you
were waiting things about population the
angles three degrees which is basically
perfect which I still find very very
stunning so so the other way to say it
is I've written up there for example if
you choose generation and minimize
changes in precip you can cut the preset
bye-bye eighty-seven percent like this
thirteen percent residual on a region by
region basis so I find that very
surprising because the radiative
forcings really seem quite different and
I think it's interesting to think about
why this is true and why it might not be
true I don't think this is just an
artifact of this model to be clear I
don't believe these exact numbers if you
used a different model than slightly
different numbers but broadly my sense
is that most models have responses that
are somewhat like this and it's not
exactly clear why I should say that I
mean it's not precip that matters so
much to most impacts it's really a minus
P evaporation much precipitation a kind
of net hydrological forcing so I'm going
to just go through a couple other recent
signs papers and then kind of step back
a little bit and talk about where this
is going but I just want to give you
some so this is a geo sides audio some
sense of where people are going these
are papers that I think are kind of easy
to write because they're just playing
with models the hard part is figuring
out what are the actual trade-offs and
how we would know something more than
what's in a model but but it can be fun
to play with models so one of the
questions is how well would non
radiative forcing help so could you
optimize a little bit by choosing how to
distribute the top of the atmosphere
idea forcing in order to achieve some
objective and obviously you know the
climate is all coupled so it's not as if
you can treat each region separately and
just adjust as climate independently
because the leo we went wins in fact
moisture and temperature across the
world but it's still interesting to ask
how how much you could optimize so I've
been working on this with Doug McMartin
was a control dynamical systems guy from
Caltech and then a bunch of us had done
some climate modeling and so in this
particular paper we had we ran
ran climate models with a couple three
different top of the atmosphere
radiative forcing us so like one that
was uniform and one that was peaked in
the North repeating the South repeating
equator so three different choices for
how we do top of the atmosphere idea
forcing in a north to south sense and
then also we we gave ourselves four
seasons we could work with so we could
peak it in any one of the four seasons
and so this just shows you for example
there's a lot of worry that we're losing
sea ice so a question is how well could
you restore sea ice will doing maybe the
minimum amount of overall SRM that would
be a potentially interesting policy
question so this is for example is in
this climate model run the minimum
amount of northern hemisphere sea ice
versus tropical precip just to happen to
plot things and these dots are all the
different model runs you can get a look
at the result so the bottom line is that
doing this sort of optimum system is
significantly better than on many
metrics you care about then doing just a
uniform one percent it turns out it's
especially good at minimizing who's
worst off so if you just look a grid
point by grid point at which wich grid
point is worst off we actually make the
worst off less worse off by quite a lot
how realistic this is we can debate but
i think the central point is that if
people actually got going doing this you
wouldn't just do some kind of dumb one
time radio forcing you would do some
tuning both in response to what you
actually observed for sure and a
separate set of papers not yet published
we've been dealing with this sort of
feedback question so you know you might
argue we don't know the climate has to
be models or the world which is true but
we're not making a one-time decision
about whether or not to Geoengineer let
me let me say that yep
and you reassure me that you talked
about changing the distribution for
example of the self headed platitude yep
and trying to maintain that yep bye you
know letting it evolve as I'm putting it
out very yeah whether you could do that
with sulfate or not we don't know so so
you could clearly do it with some kind
of magic orbiting solar system with
sulfate we so we're building an ravu
building additions to geo scam model
that having a better sulfate aerosol
model for the stratosphere to attempt to
begin to do at least one step more
realistic simulations of how you could
manipulate the sulfate in three
dimensions so nobody's even done that
once yet and so I wouldn't claim that
you could necessarily do this with
sulfate I mean you could remember though
it's a linear thing so you can you make
an exact distribution like this no but
you could probably make one that was a
little more on the equator than the
poles for example and the final thing
that we find out here is no surprise you
find that if you really want to make
more sea ice you want to peek into the
northern hemisphere over the summer
which you could kind of absolutely
absolutely so most most of the models
that we've run we assume that you're
injecting in a plot a plus to minus 20
or 30 degrees at about 20 or 25
kilometers altitude basically in the
tropics counting on brewer Dobson to do
the rest that's that's the sort of base
case model that's in Pierce at all but
but you could imagine I mean yeah yes is
the answer another interesting question
I'll just show one slide from this paper
so in policy terms people often assume
I'm not sure I buy it but it's a common
assumption that you would do this stuff
only if you found out the climate
sensitivity was very high so right we
don't know the climate sensitivity we're
gradually adding co2 we can't just back
up co2 accumulates the atmosphere will
gradually find out how sensitive the
climate is and one way to think about
this
you do it in an emergency situation
which I actually don't like that
phrasing i'm using phrasing other people
use it gets a bit of a rhetorical trick
but the idea would be that you do this
in a situation where you found out the
climate was extremely sensitive to co2
and so Kate Ricky and I and I figured
who else on a paper gradual Morgan and
Ingram wanted to look at the question of
whether or not worlds that had higher
sensitivity have different responses to
SRM because one potential one
possibility is that it turns out that
the worlds that have high sensitivity
don't work for SRM for some reason or
work less well and so you're being over
optimistic if you think that you can
just use it in a high-sensitivity world
so the climate prediction net system
that presumably many of you know about
they've built ensembles of client malls
or they have hundreds of models with
different physics they systematically
perturb the physics of cloud models
they've run these monster multi-model
ensembles so we use those and selected
use those with a geoengineering and a
base case simulation and then selected
the models that were very high climate
sensitivity in the climates st
distributions you see from that group
and ask basically is the response to SRM
different and the answer is not much but
there's a nature climate change paper
about it just to say that people are
beginning just beginning I haven't done
it for myself yet to to go a step beyond
looking just crudely a temperature in
preset but actually start ask about
climate impacts so if you think about
climate science and policy overall
there's a huge amount of physical
science work understanding the climate
system its response to co 2 and so on
there's a huge amount of work that
appears in IPCC working group to on what
are the climate impacts and there's
basically been close to no effort three
papers maybe that have to some impact we
might actually directly care about for
humans think about how well SRM might
work or not work to reduce that impact
so this is one example from a paper that
too julia pod rats and Kenna caldera and
it's really relying on the crop
temperature models of David LaBelle
and and those models our intern really
tied two observations in a way that I
think is very very strong although there
are people who argue about them and
those models fundamentally say that one
of the big impacts of climate change
will be peak temperatures during
germination season and indeed low bells
models as I knew Regina shearing
suggests that we're already losing
several percent of global productivity
because of that so these are some
simulations which do show that when you
do SRM you can significantly get a
significant of productivity back that is
it the world that you have a world that
is a high co2 world with SRM a
significantly higher crop productivity
for most important crops in most places
not everywhere then a world would high
co2 and no SRM so I've talked a little
bit about some measures of efficacy you
know serious work to look at efficacy is
really just beginning I would say
there's all sort of stuff that hasn't
been done there's easy papers just lying
out there to be written looking at
variability for example you might expect
so one of the things we all know that's
a risk of climate change is that the
hydrological cycle gets more variable as
it gets more intense when you add more
co2 although there's a slight counter
fact counter of fact that you're
decreasing all to wait or gradient but
if you do co2 at SRM you don't increase
the hydrological cycles so much so
you're going to tend to dampen the
variability I think nobody's published
paper saying that yet I did get Kate to
look at that and I did turn out to be
true and it's like a tiny footnote and
one of those one of kids Kate rookies
papers but we need to actually look at
it carefully and I've heard other people
who I respect argue that it won't be
true so I don't know this is pretty much
all about models so far and models are
not the same as reality of course these
are the same models mostly as we use to
understand the risks of increasing co2
but but you really do have to think
about how you manage this problem when
you only have one planet and you don't
know
exactly how the system will respond i
think a fundamental so a couple things
to say um if you asked me personally to
make a choice between implementing
geoengineering right you know now with
say sulfates to compensate for the
entire effect of all at approach and
greenhouse gases and I made a one-time
decision for like 100 years or to a bad
the GM attorney forever I would choose
abandonment so I think if you think
about this is a one-time decision like
that it's almost certainly not heed to
do it the answer these are just very
very large and it's also true that
comets anyway all of two times co2 is is
almost certainly a bad idea but that is
not the choice we face not even remotely
first of all the main joists we do space
now should we actually have a serious
research program but beyond that there's
by no means right that you should
compensate all the two times T or 2 i'll
show you some figures to show you why I
think that's foolish and and if you did
it at all you would presumably do it in
a gradual way and i'll show you specific
a kind of example for what i mean by
doing the glacial way and you would
monitor looking for side effects as you
went there's another one of the papers
with dub magnum a ski me ken caldera
that was published in an earth and the
royal society journal es energy
environmental science it looks at some
of the signal-to-noise questions when
you could start to detect a signal and
how you might modulate your way up to
detect give yourself the best chance to
detect bad side effects before you saw
anything so i think in reality you do
something like that you wouldn't just
flick a switch and turn it on so first
of all let me deal with this question of
i already gave you this idea about
impacts but let me just give you this
there a basic argument that it makes no
sense to x co2 for some of you who
aren't reading the literature on this
this might be so obvious it's snoozy but
what's amazing is most of the climb
model simulations that have been done
have affected a deal have assumed
effective legal SRM deals with the full
two times co2 and then they've talked
about the risks of SRM as being what's
left over after dual two times co2 and
that was a convenient climate modeling
thing to do because it gives you a good
it annoys and and as a piece of science
there's nothing wrong with it but if
people translate that in their heads to
something that relates to public policy
it's done and that's the key point I'm
trying to make here so benefits actually
this is actual real data the next plot
i'm going to show you is imagine data
but this is real data or it's the action
that actual variance number on a grid
plug or group point bottle and so the
point is this is some reduction in this
mean square temperature and precip
deviation and this is versus the
reduction solar constant so so so i'm
getting benefits because i'm reducing
harms and so as i start here reducing
the solar constant i get this pretty
steep reduction in the overall change
but at some point it peaks and then it
gets worse and worse if i reduce the
solar constant by eight or ten percent
for a hundred years according to two
papers i get used cells back to the
neoproterozoic snowball earth and kill
everything on the surface i'm not
suggesting we do that but it's clearly
not true that if some generation is good
lots of jewish hearing is good this is
not the optimal mataji measuring this is
the point where you get the absolute
minimization of change but there's also
going to be bad side effects of jewish
sharing this is a made-up figure but
presumably ozone loss or various other
bad side effects are probably going to
grow faster than linearly so if i add up
it's just sort of like econ 101 if i add
up something it kind of has a peak like
that with something else that's growing
faster linearly this number was invented
this is just my mathematic i just want
the curve here i'm going to have and i
add the two together and then i'm
looking at something more like the
optimization between costs and benefits
the peak is for sure going to be quite a
bit to this side so that's the basic
argument that says you might not want to
do choose I of co2 there's also kind of
policy component which is I think we
still want to cut emissions quickly at
least that's what I think we should do
and and so I think leaving some of the
effect on corrected so there's more of a
tender cut emissions might be good
policy so overall my sense is that if
you actually want to do this you want to
do a relatively small amount of it
so let's make a specific proposal let's
say you wanted to partially counteract
co2 driven climate change and and
specifically you might decide to reduce
the rate of warming by 50% starting in
2020 let's just put the numbers in for
what that means so that means to 2020
you do nothing but at the end of the
year you've got to put in enough sulfate
aerosol to correct for half of the radio
forcing increase that turns out to be
25,000 tons of sulfur by the end of that
first year and that takes two of these
gulfstream aircraft just to give you a
sense of how easy this would be to do
single day's each additional year you've
got to do you've got to keep adding on
so after 10 years and 2030 you're
putting in a quarter roughly a quarter
million tons of sulfate at that point
the sulfate is is barely up to the
natural background but not quite so it's
important to say you're starting slowly
it started well below the natural
background here there's a natural
background of sulphur getting in the
stratosphere anyway and if you do that
for 50 years you're up to still under
just under a million tons a year in 2070
which I don't want to claim that this is
no risk but the point is we know some
things that are empirical not models
that tell us real with some confidence
what there is my biggest remember
Pinatubo is eight million tons of one
year so that gives you some sense into
bahut a lots of impacts but it gives you
some sense that we can say something
quantitative that is tied to real
observations and not just models not
that I don't trust models necessarily
about what the impacts might be when we
go out up to say at 2070 and that's a
long time I mean that's what cuts 32
warming in half for half a century which
has real benefits to humans who are live
now and I that's sort of important case
for how to think about this here's a
little fun yep
the cost per year of doing that if you
did sulfur all the way out you can look
you can look up that URL paper but think
of it as being a billion dollars a year
by 2017 round numbers but you probably
switch to some other kind of aerosol so
this is just I actually want to be a
little bit numerical about it there's a
common statement that for instance
rapier Humbert who's a very very smart a
thoughtful guy makes which is that once
you start you measuring you have to do
forever so this is just not true just
isn't true and you're a nose is not true
there are big benefits if you do it only
temporarily that's not to say that you
should do it there are very good
arguments not to do it but the argument
that if you do have to do it forever is
not one of them so many climate impacts
depend on the rate of change and so if
you did SRM this is millions of times a
year sulfate so this is the same rap i
showed you up to 1 million times here
and then wrapping back down toward zero
so the point is by the time you get back
down to zero here in a simple climate
model here i've got radio forcing she's
a simple impulse response function model
like she did another train this morning
by the time you get out to here there's
absolutely no benefit for SRM basically
you stop that surrounds there's no
benefit the point is long long term
climate change depends on how much co2
we put in the air and if we want to
reduce the long-term climate risk we
have to stop putting co2 in the air
period nothing about SRM changes that
but it's also true that if you do SRM
temporarily you can flatten out the peak
and reduce the overall rate of change of
temperature and there's very strong
evidence of Club an impasse community
that the rate of change of temperature
is a big role in setting impacts so you
can meaningfully reduce impacts if all
you do is is do some what we might think
was peak shaving you do feel engineering
for a while up to the point where you
brought emissions down to about zero and
then you tapered reassuring back down to
zero and that has may or may not be a
good idea but it definitely reduces the
standard measures of risk and it
definitely doesn't commit you to do
janitoring forever
this should be a progressive thing you
would never just start doing it as I
said you start with lab modeling with
impacts you're going to find problems
then I believe that you should start
thinking about specific very small
experiments again its specific
atmospheric processes these are not
experiments are trying to actually
perturb the climate their experiments
what you're trying to find out whether a
specific process works the way you think
so crude has been looking at this
question of whether some particular
nuclei would reduce serious in some
place you could go out and do an
experiment on a scale of 100 square
kilometers in principle and that
experiment the goal of that would not be
to manipulate the Earth's climate the
goal would be to understand whether
specific piece of Trudy's model was
correct and similarly Jimenez and I are
beginning to do engineering and science
work developing experiment that would
put water vapor and/or sulfate in a
small volume think of it as being a few
cubic kilometers this is a we're talking
about a thousand kilos of water so less
than one transatlantic aircraft flight
and we would measure some of the
specific risks that we don't know well
enough about the ozone chemistry
interactions that would be a
manipulative experiment of the
atmosphere which is an unusual thing and
there are real issues about how we
regulate a govern those but it's pretty
clear that they don't alter the climate
their goal isn't auto climate to do
processing studies quite separately from
that you could do minimal scale
deployment that at that point it's not
an experiment at that point you are
manipulating the planet and we need some
governance system that manages that I
don't know what it is I've got
suggestions and that's where these paper
for example the back to mouse key paper
yes deals with the signal-to-noise
question of when you could first detect
a very minimal deployment like this and
then only if you did that you'd begin
gradual deployment so the idea the point
here is to say that that hole on the
point is to is to say that to try and
shake you from the notion that our
choice is whether or not we should do
this all together and I think the choice
is really whether or not we do research
whether we begin if the research pans
out which it may not so one thing
research may do is show that
this idea is much worse than some of us
think and that's a healthy thing it's
good if we know that so let me say a
little bit just of the closing couples
three slides about what my fears are my
fears are actually mostly not about the
sort of narrowly conceived technical
risks I think those risks are real but
that I don't think they're the big risks
and this is getting into a little bit of
the policy talk I'll talk about in the
afternoon there is real potential for
conflict here the fact that it is so
easy and cheap to manipulate the Earth's
climate this way if you if you gave that
power to a completely unbiased a
political panel of people who you know
had in some global rosy and democratic
view of the humanities best interests
and they had time on their hands to
think it through carefully then it's I
think pretty likely that having this
extra ability would actually be useful
in reducing climate risk but that's not
the world we live in and in the world we
live in you could imagine outcomes that
are really horrific if different
countries have different views about how
much to do and then as well as that they
have different they have the slow and
stochastic nature or political
decision-making just for fun we've
actually been making we've been doing
these models where we do feedback
control of the climate for fun and we
put delays in to show kind of that if
politicians are slow making decisions
you can get oscillations and you can of
course so I think that you could have
really horrific outcomes there's also
this question that it's a little more
fuzzy that that in some way this
represents humans really officially
making the planet an artifact in a way
that's different from just making a mess
I believe and there's actually was a
series of articles between me and Brad
Allen be where he argued they were the
same and I argue that there's a
difference between making a mess in
deliberately engineering so a key thing
is what's the goal here everything I've
been saying so far as to assumes that
the goal is somehow to minimize the risk
of co2 address climate change so I
difficulty there's no gold you just
learn stuff for policy terms that's only
one of many goals another goal might be
to say maximize productivity and if that
was the goal you might actually want
more co2 in the air
and then do some geoengineering as well
permanently I'm not saying that is the
goal but I'm saying we're gonna have to
deal with this question of what the goal
is Tom shelling I've been privileged to
serve on the panel with him on this
recently he's thought about this for a
long time these are words he wrote in
the nineteen eighty-two National Academy
report on geoengineering and I mean the
whole report was in geometry but those
that there's a section of it on geo
missionary and I think I think Tom I
checked that those were Tom's words I
asked him I think he nailed it interest
in co2 may generate or reinforce a
lasting interest in national or
international means of climate a weather
modification and what's generated they
may flourish independent of what's done
about co2 once we get into the business
of manipulating the planet to get some
outcome then people are going to start
to ask for different outcomes that's
what happens when you invent new
technologies like this and the people
who invent the technologies don't get to
decide how they're used there's this
whole easy out moral hazard problem and
i think is often misconceived i'm gonna
deal without a lot in my talk is
afternoon i won't say much here except
to the basics you know that's the
fundamental worry that everybody has
it's important to say that this is just
some extent we're making a pitiful claim
here so the opposite is possible it's
possible that pointy-headed scientists
saying that we need to contemplate
something this scary will actually
encourage action there are lots of ways
in which you can argue that you
measuring might make the politics easier
Marky Weitzman has made these arguments
so I don't think it's simple to say that
it necessarily makes it harder you can
make arguments on both sides this this
does a better job I think than any
papers capturing this idea these tom
toles cartoons that the punch line is
always the bottom so the search for
breakthrough technology to solve climate
change continues this guy says the time
machine that will take us back 50 years
when we should have put a price on
carbon then this guy says we better
hurry up and this guy says no no it's
the great idea about a time machine it
doesn't matter when you do it and and
that captures some of the moral hazard
idea here did that you you know cheers
journey has some aspects of a time
machine in the sense in a sense that
putting carbon in the atmosphere a week
without one of the two kinds of joy
machinery and carbon removal or srn but
in carbon the amateur is pretty much a
one-way valve
the reasonable time scales the climate
change is just the integral the total
carbon we put in period and so in a
sense it's sort of marching forward in
time you always get worse if you're
putting in carbon in these things allow
you some measure of time machines on
measurability of your backwards then of
course they're all the actual side
effects and risks which I don't mean to
minimize but i think that the big issues
are more how we manage those risks than
the Objectivists themselves from what
i've seen so far thank you very much
precipitation they might see the club
and you get attorney or nearby hip and
that gets something to do the court of
why suddenly somebody is responsible for
what used to be thought of as a natural
event so I can just imagine
even the most innocuous kind of seeding
of the stratosphere the sulfates could
maybe have nothing to do with
thunderstorms each our tables what
jury's going to know that for sure judge
is going to be able to something you're
responsible me personally yeah that's
why give a death threats seriously
actually but yes that's exactly right
and so in in the those you interested
that I felt that there was a article I
wrote now 15 years ago an aerial views
energy environment where I went back and
read about these early reports and I
found the very same thing so the there
was this huge boom in cloud seeding in
the late 40s of the US I think it's
pretty likely essentially none of it did
almost anything but there was an
enormous commercial boom with cloud
seeding and as a result there was a huge
number of lawsuits with farmers suing
other farmers for loss of rain and that
was brought to Congress and they form
the Advisory Committee on climate of
weather control which if you look at
committee membership is essentially
leads all the way to the IPCC that's the
beginning of having a formal US
government committee that deals with
these topics because that committee that
started in 53 if I remember my date
right that committee just kind of blends
in to the committee's that then had
rivale on them and people in the mid-60s
the beginning to think about the modern
version what we call the climate problem
and on and on so so that's exactly where
some of the started I completely agree
and and and the liability concerns here
have always been central people have
talked about the problems of managing
liability from Jewish sharing back in
fact two papers in the 60s because there
are papers and safety so the idea is
absolutely real and important it's not
clear so recently is now this topics got
really hot and we have lots of people
working on we think about it we've got
some legal scholars at Harvard started
think about this and several other
groups to start to think more hard about
it it is a head-scratcher it's certainly
a real issue but there is a lot of
international I mean what we've been
doing is probably looking at other
international liability machines from
oil spills onward there are lots of them
there's the outer space treaty some of
them sort of work
there are lots of ways you could go
either inside current international sort
of what's called effective the
equivalent of common law war by adding
new laws like some existing ones that I
think give you some potential to do it
there's also this ties the question of
liability for co2 change itself so there
have been attempts including a very
important attempts by a bunch of
attorneys generals of US states to sue
coal-fired power plants as a public
nuisance and there have been other
attempts around the world that have some
legal traction on them exceeded to sue
some of the companies that have the
longest corporate history of co2
emissions for contribution to to climate
change and you can learn a lot from most
lawsuits I would say this problem is not
unique to SRM but it's definitely a
problem but it's intimately coupled the
question of whether you can claim
damages for the co2 emissions and
there's also some possibility that we've
been investigate whether you could sue
to ask that sue because SRM wasn't done
so if you're an Indian farmer and you
have good science to suggest that the
doing semester arm would have saved your
crops and the Indian government knew it
can you sue them to argue you should
have done it it's a lot of room for
lawyers concerned about
this is relatively cheaply your state
actors Reynolds there yeah so whether
there's conflict that could arise
because different states have different
interests in two different ink so you're
talking about like a terrorist action to
do it is that what you mean yeah um
might know or not much I've had some
dinner conversations with Oliver Martin
who's a very thoughtful writer on these
topics he was a lead nature writer it's
in nature and now is writing a book on
this I believe that it is theoretically
possible to do this surreptitiously I I
don't think it works in a meaningful way
as a terrorist tool there is a paper
I've never actually read that Mike
McElroy wrote a few decades ago about
adding bromine the stratosphere is a
terrorist tool so they're certainly
ideas out there but I just don't see
them as being credible compared to other
things that terrorists could do I don't
want to get to use the word terrorist
the people who want to threaten other
people in that way could do could you
you had towards the end you describe
basically what I call an experiment so
aside from the liability and legal
issues what's the scale of an experiment
that would give you enough information
you know to help you improve your
modulus going forward and where would
you do it so the planet so the point is
there's these two very different things
there's experiments on processes or what
you're fundamentally trying to do is
understand something that a client model
our calls it part of the process model
that really is understanding how some
microphysics interacts and those
experiments um you could do in the lab
some experiments you might want to do
outside but but in general you did with
the smallest scale where you could get
good signal to noise because the
objective isn't to change the climb is
understand the process so the one that
you matter said and I are designing we
would distribute about a thousand kilos
of water from a balloon at about 25
kilometres in a kind of long plume that
would be about 10 kilometers long on a
kilometer or so wide
and we would be looking for the way that
water perturb the knox chemistry to
check our understanding that nas
chemistry and we would do it also with
sulfates and we basically you might say
why not do in the lab the answer is as
you know if you know I was here
chemistry it's it's extraordinarily hard
to see me in that lab because you've got
the diurnal cycle you've got strong UV
you've got these radicals of the dutch
walls they're gone and they're real
limits what we can do the lab so that
would be a process study you can imagine
process studies going off the kind of
stuff that trudat has talked about as
well and those studies are not that
different from current atmospheric
observational campaigns they be there in
their actual environmental impacts would
be very small um we would do whatever
was convenient cuz there's no I mean to
be clear this is less see less water
vapor than one transatlantic aircraft
flight so just there's no I mean there
are risks yeah well there are I mean I'm
actually have some experiences such as
gym running real experiments like this
there are dangerous but the dangers are
really not from the emissions different
to the pilots I mean if you fly any fly
balloon the stratosphere those dangers
yeah the balloon payloads can fall down
and kill people that's true whether it's
a just make any difference in it's a
Jewish earning balloon it's the same if
it's a telescope so there are real risks
that you have to deal with but that's
kind of normal risk management and then
and this is really the alto be this
afternoon this is really the point of
the paper that Ted person I published in
science a few weeks ago about how to do
the governance there's a very big
difference in scale between those
experiments which are inherently kind of
want to be small which are process
experiments experiments are a big enough
scale to test large gastric response to
do that you've got to make the response
big enough to see above the signal above
the noise and and that turns out to be
really big so like a tenth of a watt per
square meter modulated over ten years to
see it at that point that's not an
experiment I mean yeah I mean you're
basically you're doing it in a closed
loop way and I think at that point you
don't pretend this is a science
experiments kind of actively doing it
and looking for problems and I don't
think there's much in between because
there's not a lot of reason to do things
at the middle scale right now so we
propose that those get treated very
differently than right now you have a
moratorium on doing the big
and that you allow the small stuff under
some scale